[Aplausos]
o atuário gente
hoje estou aqui vejo tanta gente boa
falando à bbc
mas então alguém falou isso pra vocês
sobre sonho e eu sei que ele tem ele
chama projeto ajude a tornar esse sonho
é time de idade ela me mandou eu
abraçada aos trancos e até hoje precisa
da vitória e feito criança imagina pra
casa da minha parte acho muito mais nas
ruas mas muito mesmo de quando criança e
pensando meu deus quem tinha medo que eu
tenho
eu eo meu filho gosta e acho nosso
cachorro lá e prá ela começou a ser mais
exigente comigo hoje
até lá eu comecei a gente sentia esse
episódio e assim é a gente fazer alguma
coisa maior
é um trabalho diferente um trabalho de
formiguinha que nós e as pessoas
envolvem muitas não serem conhecidas
precisa de ajuda o negócio ficando a
precisar fazer funcionar uma idéia eu
não sei que todas as ruas porque não é
melhorar as condições dele mesmo e eu
cheguei lá vai lá vai
foi atrás de recursos outros de enfim a
gente dividiu a tarefa começou a
trabalhar em prol da causa de um vídeo e
uma boa risada e ajudou muito nesse
projeto
[Música]
cheguei para ele e falei na rua olha eu
sei mas é complicado
o pessoal olha aí o trabalho mas assim é
parte de um júri
[Música]
as ruas bahia hoje 12 tiros na cabeça
são passados porque a gente consiga uma
partilha o projeto de uma empresa de
curso muito é novo
mesmo assim porque o nosso público e do
projeto é importante a conscientização
nas escolas
então a gente falar demais
este processo de adoção corpo e agora
pra vocês
acontece que o projeto nacional e
garante que muitas pessoas sabem o que
acontecia conosco em um estado onde eu
comecei a pessoa assim que tinha nomeado
assim e de vários hotéis é dos insulares
formar o projeto aqui na gávea foi então
tem outras que também querem delas são
paulo é que o projeto
vocês terem uma idéia hoje 18 municípios
em santa catarina vem realizando faladas
nas ruas baseados no projeto e também
fazendo um trabalho de capacitação e
conscientização nas escolas é possível
fazer alguma coisa e isso me deixou
muito feliz porque foi aqui que a gente
montou porque é o final de 2016 começou
[Música]
a idéia é que todas as casinhas sempre
com a pele para assegurar que alguém vai
sair porque é impossível né o final de
2008 214 que nem todas estão bem
cuidadas outras assim sobe a gente
entende né
eu cheguei e fotos das crianças lá
embaixo
eles muito contentes de sair fazendo
alguma coisa porque eles serão
importantes
isso porque falar a gente achou para a
criança é a coisa mais pura que existe é
é por ele tem centrado e eu nunca ouvi
uma ficha e uma criança ou a criança
falando uma coisa negativa com relação à
igual
por isso acredito muito na criação né
ele disse nas crianças a cuidar dos
animais nestas crianças a cuidar das
plantas criadas responsabilidade social
em desde cedo porque é isso a agência
quando eu ia ela sim negociando assim ó
problema é a menina sozinha no chão né
e eu fico muito feliz em muito
agradecido porque eu percebo que é só
está mudando e talvez 27 anos seja muito
longe
é pra isso nosso trabalho pensando no
futuro melhor
[Aplausos]